5500 to start 55 5.5 million dollars to
start it
good start
it's 1994
and we're watching an auction in a sales
room at christie's in manhattan 19
million 500 000 next bid is 20 20
million on sale is a one-of-a-kind
leonardo da vinci manuscript known as
the codex hammer
25 million
at 25 million in this room
now the audience in the room doesn't
know this but a representative for
microsoft co-founder bill gates is
bidding on the phone
at 28 million dollars it's away from the
room now and on the telephone 28 million
dollars
gates is up against a group from a bank
in milan that's sitting in the front of
the room
on the telephone in this room at 28
million dollars last call and in the end
thank you
the manuscript goes to gates
[Music]
back in november 1994 bill gates was 39
years old and had just appeared atop our
forbes 400 ranking of the richest
americans
and gates who is a big lover of books
sort of goes out and gets the ultimate
book
a leonardo da vinci manuscript that he
buys for 28 million
which comes out to 30.8 million dollars
with auction closing fees
the manuscript today is known as the
codex lester named for the british earl
whose estate owned it for more than 250
years
it's a collection of da vinci's writings
and illustrations mostly focused on his
study of water
according to the provenance in the
auction catalog a few italian artists
owned the codex after da vinci's death
including a painter named giuseppe getzi
who apparently sold it in 1717 to thomas
cook a man who eventually became
england's earl of leicester
it stayed with the earl of leicester's
estate until 1980 when it finally went
up for auction
oil tycoon arm and hammer bought it that
year
and 14 years later gate spotted at
another auction
it's the only one of da vinci's
notebooks that's still in private hands
today
there are about 360 illustrations inside
these pages and the text is done in da
vinci's signature what's called mirror
writing that is he wrote backwards
one other thing to note is that the
original version that gates owns is not
bound like my copy here
while at one time it was bound by
another owner centuries later that
binding has since been removed and today
each page is held in plexiglas
so how much is the codex worth today
so
art is one of the toughest things that
we have to value for our list because
the value is just so subjective
it's really worth what somebody will pay
for it and you never know when a
billionaire is gonna just be very moved
by a piece and pay
uh an amount of money that you couldn't
even imagine something might have been
worth
to get that piece so you just really
never know what something is gonna go
for until it hits the option block
books have value for their rarity for
their importance to history or
literature if it's a work of fiction
um the first appearance of something so
once we've decided that the book is
worth looking at for its condition
for its provenance
the first question we're asking but
we're going to ask it again is what are
we actually looking at if it's a first
edition of moby dick
that's a great thing to have then we
look at the condition and we base the
condition on what's in our hands and how
you look at a book that's 150 170 years
old darren shared with us some of the
important qualities that make books
valuable things like condition and
rarity
but he told us that he wasn't a da vinci
or codex expert and was hesitant to put
a value on it out of the gate so next we
decided to try talking with some experts
who were more familiar with old masters
works and da vinci my name is robert
simon i am an art dealer in new york i
work as well as an art appraiser
my background is as an art historian
in 1993 robert simon was hired by the
trustees of the arm and hammer museum to
do an appraisal of the codex lester back
when it was known as the codex hammer
you may have heard of robert simon
before because he and a colleague bought
the salvatore mundi in 2005 for just
over one thousand dollars in a louisiana
auction my feeling was that the codex
was quite a bit more valuable than any
single drawing would be so that was kind
of the basic first principle what by
leonardo can we compare it with and then
how do we rationalize the difference in
the kind of object it is and its size
he also pulled together works of art
that he found it to be similar to those
included other drawings by da vinci one
by michelangelo and one painting by
another renaissance artist named
pantormo
ultimately simon decided that the
codex's value was 50 million dollars in
1993.
so it's difficult to get much better
than someone who has already appraised
the work of art that we're trying to
value
but just to be safe we also contacted
some other da vinci and rare book
experts and scholars who we thought
might know the work well too
everyone spoke with the caveat that we
could never really know what the codex
is worth until it actually goes up for
auction
so in the end we decided to take the
average of all the recommendations we
got from our expert sources
everyone agreed like robert simon said
that were it to go up for auction today
it would not draw more than the
salvatore monday which sold for 450
million a da vinci painting is much
rarer than davinci's words and sketches
he spent
much more time as a writer scientist
draftsman than he did as a painter and
so you've got the painting itself is you
know much more a rare object but no one
thought it was still worth the 30.8
million gates paid for it we decided to
take the average of every expert's
opinion which worked out to about 130
million dollars
this means the codex is certainly one of
the world's most valuable pieces of art
but it makes up about 0.1 of bill
gates's 134 billion dollar fortune
according to a cnbc report the median
net worth of someone who is 65 years old
which is gates's age
is about 266 000
so gates buying leonardo da vinci's
notebook is the equivalent of a typical
65 year old splurging on a new ipad
billionaires just live in a different
world
[Music]
you